Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Four: visual art and sculpture.
Let's start with a treasure from the Bronze Age.
The oldest examples of visual art and decoration of objects in Denmark go far back in time.
The most important treasure from the oldest times is the so-called Solvognen, the Sun Chariot, a figure that represents the sun being pulled by a horse.
The Sun Chariot dates from the older Bronze Age, about 1350 before Christ.
In the religion of that time the sun was worshipped, and the Sun Chariot shows how the sun was pulled across the sky during the day by one of its helpers, a horse.
A snake, a fish and two ships led the sun through the rest of the hours of the day and night.
The Sun Chariot is made of gold and bronze.
It was found in Trundholm Mose in North West Zealand.
In 1639 and 1734, a big gold find was made in the form of the golden horns from Gallehus in South Jutland.
They were decorated with many figures and with runes.
The golden horns date from about 400 after Christ.
They were stolen and melted down in 1802.
They have been recreated on the basis of drawings, but details of the decoration are uncertain.
With the introduction of Christianity in Denmark from the 900s, church art comes to Denmark.
It mixes with the Viking Age's decorations with human and animal figures.
This can be seen, among other things, on Harald Bluetooth's Jelling stone from the second half of the 900s, where Jesus is shown as a strong and victorious Viking warrior.
The many newly built churches of the Middle Ages, roughly 1050 to 1500, were equipped with wall paintings, kalkmalerier, which functioned as a kind of comic strips.
The paintings were to help ensure that the large majority of the population, who could not read the Bible and did not understand Latin, which was the language of the church until the Reformation, could also grasp the message of Christianity.
An example is the wall paintings of Bible stories in Birkerød Church north of Copenhagen.
After the Reformation in 1536, it was especially the king and the nobility who used art to show their wealth and importance.
The many impressive works of art at Kronborg in Helsingør demonstrate the king's power, including 40 woven tapestries showing Danish kings.
Christian the Fourth had a particularly great interest in art and culture and had several well-known foreign painters come to Denmark to paint the king and his family, and to decorate the king's many castles.
With the introduction of absolutism in 1660 to 61, power was centralised in the king.
To be able to educate Danish artists who could measure up to those abroad, Frederik the Fifth, who reigned from 1746 to 66, founded the Royal Danish Academy of Fine Arts at Charlottenborg at Kongens Nytorv in Copenhagen, where it still has its home.
A work from this period which is regarded as a high point in Danish art history is the French Jacques-François-Joseph Saly's equestrian statue of Frederik the Fifth from 1771, which stands in the middle of Amalienborg Palace Square and is regarded as one of Europe's most beautiful equestrian statues.
The statue by the way cost more to erect than Amalienborg's four palaces put together.
The first half of the 1800s has been given the name the Golden Age, Guldalderen, because Danish culture, art and science flourished with several internationally known names.
For example the author H.C.
Andersen, who lived from 1805 to 75, the philosopher Søren Kierkegaard, 1813 to 55, who lived in the 1800s, the physicist H.C.
Ørsted, 1777 to 1851, the poet Adam Oehlenschläger, 1779 to 1850, and N.F.S.
Grundtvig, 1783 to 1872.
A famous artist from the Golden Age is Bertel Thorvaldsen, who lived from 1770 to 1844, and is the best-known sculptor in Danish history.
In 1797 he travelled to Italy and lived in Rome for many years.
Here he created, inspired by the art of the Roman Empire, a series of sculptures, among other things the tomb monument of Pope Pius the Seventh.
In 1838 Thorvaldsen returned to Denmark.
His sculptures got their own museum, Thorvaldsens Museum, which is in Copenhagen.
The museum opened in 1848 and was the first museum building in Denmark that the population had access to.
Here are exhibited Thorvaldsen's sculptures as well as his own collection of paintings and art objects from ancient antiquity about 2,000 years ago.
In painting, C.W.
Eckersberg, who lived from 1783 to 1853, is one of the most important artists from the Golden Age.
Eckersberg, among other things, went on a study stay in Rome with Thorvaldsen.
He worked with motifs from the landscape and the folk life around Rome.
In the time after, painters such as Vilhelm Hammershøi, who lived from 1864 to 1916, have marked Danish visual art.
Vilhelm Hammershøi has not least been appreciated by posterity for his ability to paint light and shadow in the rooms of a home.
His painting "Interiør fra Strandgade 30" was painted in the year 1900 and depicts the painter's wife Ida, who stands reading in the couple's home in Christianshavn in Copenhagen.
The painting was in 2023 sold at an auction in the USA for 62.8 million kroner, and thereby became the most expensive Danish painting ever sold.
Other significant painters from the same period, kunstmalere, are P.S.
Krøyer, who lived from 1851 to 1909, and the married couple Anna Ancher, 1859 to 1935, and Michael Ancher, 1849 to 1927, who belong to the circle of the so-called Skagen Painters.
Towards the end of the 1800s, a number of painters settled in Skagen, which is Denmark's northernmost town.
They painted both the local population's everyday life and the painters' own lives.
The light from the two seas, Skagerrak and Kattegat, which surround Skagen, came to play a special role in their pictures.
Anna Ancher's painting "Solskin i den blå stue", "Sunshine in the Blue Room", is from 1891.
The sculptor Anne Marie Carl-Nielsen, who lived from 1863 to 1945, was the first woman in the world to get a commission to make an equestrian statue of a king.
Today her equestrian statue of Christian the Ninth, who reigned from 1863 to 1906, can be seen at Christiansborg's Riding Ground, and she is also known for being behind the bronze doors in Ribe Cathedral.
Anne Marie Carl-Nielsen fought throughout her life for women's access to academic educations and for their right to exhibit works on an equal footing with male artists.
In more recent times, Asger Jorn, who lived from 1914 to 73, is among the world-famous Danish visual artists.
He helped found the international artists' group Cobra, which got its name from the artists' home towns Copenhagen, Brussels and Amsterdam.
Cobra existed from 1948 to 1951.
His main work is the large painting "Stalingrad", named after the city where one of the bloodiest battles of the Second World War took place in 1942 to 43, and where the Soviet Union defeated Germany.
The battle is regarded as the turning point of the war, the beginning of the final German defeat in 1945.
Jorn worked on the picture from 1957 to 72.
The dominant colour is white-grey like the snow at the city, with red splashes everywhere, which symbolise blood.
Three of the most important visual artists in recent decades are Per Kirkeby, who lived from 1938 to 2018, Bjørn Nørgaard, born 1947, and Lene Adler Petersen, born 1944.
Kirkeby is internationally recognised for his large abstract paintings, which relate to a natural world, and his pictures have been exhibited all over the world.
Lene Adler Petersen has worked with both film, actions, graphics, painting and sculpture.
In 1969, she and her husband Bjørn Nørgaard created the action "Den kvindelige Kristus", "The Female Christ", where she walked naked through the Stock Exchange, Børsen, in Copenhagen with a cross in her hand.
The action became an icon of a new experimental and critical art aimed at capitalist and male-dominated norms.
An important newer artwork is Bjørn Nørgaard's main work consisting of 17 large tapestries, gobelins, which decorate the Knights' Hall at Christiansborg and tell the course of Danish history from the Viking Age to our time.
The tapestries were a birthday present from a number of business organisations, companies and others for the Queen's 50th birthday in 1990.
They took 10 years to make and were inaugurated on the Queen's 60th birthday in the year 2000.
Another artist who has made a mark in recent decades is the Danish-Icelandic Olafur Eliasson, born 1967.
One of his best-known works is Your Rainbow Panorama, in Danish Din regnbueudsigt, from 2011, on top of the art museum ARoS in Aarhus, which is a 150-metre-long circular glass walkway where you can look out over Aarhus in all the colours of the rainbow.
In Danish: a painter is a kunstmaler, a sculptor is a billedhugger, the Skagen Painters are Skagensmalerne, and absolutism is enevælde.
Here is your recap for Episode Four.
Søren Kierkegaard lived in the 1800s.
The Sun Chariot, from about 1350 before Christ, is the most important treasure from the Bronze Age; it was found in Trundholm Mose.
The golden horns from Gallehus are from about 400 after Christ, found in 1639 and 1734, stolen and melted down in 1802.
Medieval churches had wall paintings that worked like comic strips.
Frederik the Fifth founded the Royal Danish Academy of Fine Arts.
The Golden Age was the first half of the 1800s.
Bertel Thorvaldsen, 1770 to 1844, is the best-known sculptor; his museum opened in 1848.
C.W.
Eckersberg was a leading Golden Age painter.
Vilhelm Hammershøi painted the 1900 interior, sold in 2023 for 62.8 million kroner.
The Skagen Painters included P.S.
Krøyer and Anna and Michael Ancher.
Anne Marie Carl-Nielsen was the first woman in the world to get a commission for an equestrian statue of a king.
Asger Jorn founded Cobra, which existed 1948 to 1951.
Bjørn Nørgaard's 17 tapestries are in the Knights' Hall at Christiansborg.
Olafur Eliasson made Your Rainbow Panorama in 2011 in Aarhus.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What is C.W.
Eckersberg known for?
Option A: He was a painter.
Option B: He was a composer.
Option C: He was a ballet choreographer.
[DA] Hvad er C.W. Eckersberg kendt for?  A: Han var kunstmaler  |  B: Han var komponist  |  C: Han var balletkoreograf
The answer is A: He was a painter.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Han var kunstmaler
Question 2.
When did the philosopher Søren Kierkegaard live?
Option A: In the 1700s.
Option B: In the 1800s.
Option C: In the 1900s.
[DA] Hvornår levede filosoffen Søren Kierkegaard?  A: I 1700-tallet  |  B: I 1800-tallet  |  C: I 1900-tallet
The answer is B: In the 1800s.
It appeared in the June 2020 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: I 1800-tallet
Question 3.
Who designed Your Rainbow Panorama, Din regnbueudsigt, which is placed on top of the art museum ARoS in Aarhus?
Option A: Arne Jacobsen.
Option B: Olafur Eliasson.
Option C: Jørn Utzon.
[DA] Hvem har designet ”Your rainbow panorama” (Din regnbueudsigt), der er placeret oven på kunstmuseet ARoS i Aarhus?  A: Arne Jacobsen  |  B: Olafur Eliasson  |  C: Jørn Utzon
The answer is B: Olafur Eliasson.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Olafur Eliasson
Question 4.
What are Anna Ancher and Michael Ancher especially known for?
Option A: They were composers.
Option B: They were film directors.
Option C: They were painters.
[DA] Hvad er Anna Ancher og Michael Ancher særligt kendt for?  A: De var komponister  |  B: De var filminstruktører  |  C: De var kunstmalere
The answer is C: They were painters.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: De var kunstmalere
Question 5.
What is P.S.
Krøyer, 1851 to 1909, especially known for?
Option A: He was an author.
Option B: He was a composer.
Option C: He was a painter.
[DA] Hvad er P.S. Krøyer (1851-1909) særlig kendt for?  A: Han var forfatter  |  B: Han var komponist  |  C: Han var kunstmaler
The answer is C: He was a painter.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Han var kunstmaler
Question 6.
In which town in Jutland did Anna Ancher and Michael Ancher paint especially many of their pictures at the end of the 1800s?
Option A: Silkeborg.
Option B: Sønderborg.
Option C: Skagen.
[DA] Ved hvilken by i Jylland malede Anna Ancher og Michael Ancher særligt mange af deres billeder i slutningen af 1800-tallet?  A: Silkeborg  |  B: Sønderborg  |  C: Skagen
The answer is C: Skagen.
It appeared in the November 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Skagen
Question 7.
In which Danish city can you visit, among other things, Den Gamle By and the art museum ARoS?
Option A: Helsingør.
Option B: Odense.
Option C: Aarhus.
[DA] I hvilken dansk by kan man blandt andet besøge Den Gamle By og kunstmuseet ARoS?  A: Helsingør  |  B: Odense  |  C: Aarhus
The answer is C: Aarhus.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Aarhus
That's the end of this part.
Well done.